mou vice-président du groupe LR au Sénat
bonsoir Philippe Mouillet bonsoir quels
sont les enjeux pour vous de ce scrutin
sénatorial 2023 on va pas se mentir la
majorité de droite et du centre n'est
pas très inquiète ce soir non non tout à
fait donc pour nous un des enjeux c'est
justement de de pouvoir confirmer
stabiliseralement cette majorité et à
travers ça c'est aussi la la prise de
position politique la façon dont nous
traitons les sujet les textes de loi qui
est confirmé par les résultats justement
quelle doit être la stratégie de la
majorité de droite du Sénat est-ce que
elle doit être constructive avec le
gouvernement ou vraiment marquer son
opposition je crois qu'il faut qu'on
garde notre marque de frbrique c'est ça
sera la reconnaissance si les choses se
déroulent correctement dans dans les
urnes globalement on prend les textes au
fur et à mesure on a une ligne politique
qui est clair généralement nos lignes de
position sont connues et donc à chaque
texte bien nous regardons comment nous
pouvons améliorer les textes et faire en
sorte que nos idées nos convictions se
retrouvent dans les votes qui se
traduisent ici au Sénat donc c'est
vraiment un travail texte par texte
alors forcément de temps en temps avec
un lien étroit avec le gouvernement et
de temps en temps en opposition ferme
lorsqu'on n pas d'accord sur le le fond
des textes donc finalement vous faites
pas selon vous de politique politicienne
vous nêtes pas dans une opposition
systématique non non je crois queon est
surtout dans une démarche de de porter
nos convictions de porter nos choix
politiques et donc on ça se traduit par
les textes que nous votons et ça
c'est'est marqué d'autant plus dans
cette année dans la première année du
quinquen d'Emmanuel Macron finalement il
y a une relation qui s'est intensifiée
entre la droite sénatoriale et le
gouvernement notamment sur la réforme
des retraites entendu de par la
situation l'Assemblée nationale on voit
bien que le dialogue politique se passe
en grande partie aujourd'hui au Sénat et
donc en gardant cette ligne en gardant
cette volonté qu' a le présent de
l'arché de pouvoir toujours avoir je
dirais un intérêt général qui est
l'intérêt de la France et bien au fur et
à mesure on travaille sur ces textes là
et je vous dis parfois on trouve des des
accords comme pour les retraites et
inversement de temps en temps on est en
dans un affrontement ou en tout cas d'un
opposition claire en quelques mots
Philippe mouet pour finir la présidente
de la commission des affaires sociales
ici au Sénat droche ne se représente pas
est-ce que vous êtes intéressé par le
poste oui clairement j'ai fait acte de
candidature pour cette commission mais
c'est un deuxième sujet après les
élections sénatoriale oui la bataille
des commissions ce sera après ces
élections sénatoriales ici au Sénat et
voilà chaque chose en son temps mais il
y pense en se rasant Philippe
mouiller